Okay,
we're back. All right. All right. You're
back.
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, I was just asking him that you
did you have questions about
Christianity because I'm waiting to see
what kind of questions you have.
>> No, I kind of want to get back to the
same subject like you said about Allah.
>> Yeah. Allah is not out of the Bible. No.
>> Yeah. No, I was talking to my husband
like I told him my husband's Moro so
he's Arabic. Um, so he did tell me
because I now that I remember I have a
friend, he's from Jordan, too. And I
asked him that question. I'm like, "Hey,
how do you say God in Arabic?"
>> And he said, "Allah." So you as a
Syrian, you're you speak Arabic,
correct?
>> I guess you didn't hear my answer. Could
you repeat my what my answer was?
>> That you said it was a different God.
Allah is a different god.
>> That wasn't my answer. It was more than
that.
I said that just because you use the
same term doesn't mean you have the same
God in mind. For example, in the Bible
that you're appealing to,
>> John in Arabic calls Jesus Allah. So is
Jesus your Allah?
>> Jes No, because Jesus is not.
>> Jessica, you're not listening. You told
me because I speak Assyrian, no Arabic,
I use the term that's irrelevant because
in the Arabic Bible, tell your husband,
he can come and engage me. In Bible, the
word Allah is used for Jesus and the
father. John 1:1, it says, "In the
beginning was the word. The word was
with Allah." The word was Allah. And
then Hebrews 18, God the Father says to
Jesus, "Your throne, Yah Allah." So, are
you telling me your Allah is the father
and the son?
>> No. Yeah. I
can answer him.
>> Okay. Here, I'll let you My husband, he
wants to answer. Go ahead.
>> Hi.
>> Yes, sir. So, answer that question. Is
Jesus your Allah? So,
so in the Bible, the word Allah, he was
never there in the Bible to start with.
>> Oh, so you Okay. So, now we're going to
say it's not Allah. So, Allah.
>> Yeah. I go to according what you
believe. I don't go to accord you
believe. I go to according I believe
because to your in your Bible Jesus call
Allah which is the God I believe. He
call him the father.
>> No, you don't believe Allah is the
father.
>> He call him Alb in Arabic.
>> Yeah. But you don't believe that because
surah al maida 5:18 your Quran if you
now a kafir because in surah al maida
5:18 it says the Jews and Christians are
not the sons of Allah and then surah
mariam your surah open it up read in
Arabic
88 to93 it says that all you are is a
slave of Allah so I want you now to go
against the Quran and saying Allah is my
father and Muhammad's father
>> where a bad where a slave means.
That's
>> okay. One more time.
>> The Quran says you cannot be a son of
Allah or a daughter of Allah. This is
the Quran. You want me to open up the
Quran for you? I gave you the
>> Yep. Yep.
>> Okay, good.
>> Read it to me.
>> What you're going to do, what you're
going to do is then say, "Oh Allah, you
are my father and Muhammad is your son."
>> No, we don't believe that.
>> Say it again.
>> We don't believe that. We don't believe
that Muhammad is
>> telling me you believe that. And that
means the God that Jesus spoke about is
the father. So I want you to say I agree
with Jesus. God is the father of Jesus.
God is the father Muhammad and my
father. Say it.
>> Yep. Is all of us are father.
Absolutely.
>> And you just said Muhammad is a liar
because the Quran says Allah is not the
father. So make up.
>> Give me a No. Give me a Torah. Exactly.
Muhammad he said is not the father.
>> Right here. Take it easy. I'll give it
to you.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Absolutely.
>> Open up your Quran. I want you to read
in Arabic as I read in English. bring
your call.
>> Absolutely.
>> Open up for that's not about argument.
It's about you reading.
>> Absolutely.
>> No. And we don't want this in argument.
You know, it's to learn about each
other. You know,
>> that's what I and I want you to know
that you're worshiping a God that's not
the true God because he deceived you.
But that's okay. We'll get there.
>> That's okay. That's what you believe. I
respect that.
>> Oh, I I it's not. It's facts, brother.
Either I have the true God or you have
the
>> to you. It's a fact. Yes. Open up Maida
before we get there.
>> You said
Maida ayah 18. Read it for me.
>> Let me read. Let me find it first.
>> Yeah, I'll read it in English for your
wife
>> because this is in in English one.
That's why.
>> Okay. But I'll read it in English for
your wife. Okay. Can I read it in
English as you find in Arabic? Because I
want you to read in Arabic. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. I want to read in Arabic.
>> Okay. Let me read in English for her.
Okay. I want you to listen. The Jews and
Christians say
>> we are sons of Allah and his loved ones.
I want her to listen as you find your
book and confirm Arabic. The Jews and
Christians say we are sons of Allah and
his loved ones. Say why then does he
chastise you for your sins? Nay, you are
but mortals of his creating. No, you are
not his sons. He forgiveth whom he will
and chastiseth whom he will. Allah's
>> don't talk over when I recite Quran. Do
you know that's right?
>> No.
>> Allah sovereignty is stuck for Allah.
Allah is the sovereignty of the heavens
and the earth and all that is between
them and unto him is the journeying. So
I want her to listen. When the Jews and
Christians told your prophet, "We are
the sons of Allah's beloved ones." Allah
said, "No, you're not." Okay. Now read
in Arabic for her. If
>> you're not there, let me know. I'll keep
reading that until you find it.
>> You said surah, which one?
>> Chapter 5. Surah Maida. Chapter 5.
>> Chapter five. Here.
>> Chapter verse 18.
>> Chapter 5. And what uh verse?
>> Verse 18.
>> 18. Hold on.
>> On the screen, by the way, or I put it
on the screen, too.
When they say
Jesus, not Allah. Read it again. The
Jews and Christians say we are
Can you tell her what the eyes? Because
I read in English. It says, "The Jews
and Christians say what?"
>> So they and translate it for her so she
knows this translation is accurate. What
does it mean? What do they say? We are
what?
>> We are sons of God.
>> And what did your God say to them?
If you are his sons, why he punished you
when you're a sinner?
>> And then he says, "No, right. You're not
his sons."
>> But again, again,
>> I don't need your commentary. I don't
need your taps. Take it easy. Let's take
step by step.
>> You just said earlier, Allah is your
father. And then the Quran says, "No,
he's not."
>> But your father But you tell But you
tell me your father. But you tell But
you in your mind your father like my
father like B
logical father.
May Allah rebuke you for that lie. No, I
don't think Allah is a father.
>> That's what you That's what he told me.
Now,
>> do you want to talk over me and lie
about what I believe? No, I don't.
>> I'm not lie.
>> I don't lie.
>> Can you now say I want your wife to hear
this? Stop arguing because you're not
here to argue. Tell your wife, "My
sweetie, Allah is my father. Your
father, Muhammad's father, Muhammad,
>> we mean our father like how you know
it."
>> Okay, say it again.
>> I can't tell you. I can't tell you. I
can't tell you my father.
>> I can't tell you. I can't tell I love
you like my father.
>> Your husband likes to Does he do that to
you?
>> No. I I can tell you I love you like my
father. But I'm not meaning
>> say like my father. The Jews and
Christians say Allah is our father. We
are his sons.
>> Yes.
>> But your Quran says Allah is a father to
no one. Can you at least admit that?
Stop
>> because God is not or father like how we
know like father. Can you at least admit
that Allah is not the father of anyone
instead of wasting my time?
>> Yeah, but what but you you're looking
but your God is you're looking your God
is Jesus not even God.
>> Well, don't change the subject. I'm
going show you your Quran says Jesus is
the God of Muhammad.
>> But you going about you going about the
>> Stop changing the subject and bringing
up 10,000 biology. You're going by think
you don't
>> stop changing the subject and stop
embarrassing yourself front of your
wife. Can we have a respectful control
show your emotions because I hope you
don't are you okay to start with are you
imba
>> are you are you
chapter 9
>> are you
>> Jessica I can't talk your husband has no
respurah
chapter 9 verse 30 read it for her
because I want to bust your lie again
that you deceived
>> because he don't know what he's talking
about this
>> yeah I know I know that's why I'm giving
you the eye on your
>> no you don't know what you're I can give
you ayat Yeah, if you want to talk to
me, I can't answer your questions. But
if you manifest, I can.
>> No, because you're looking.
>> That's why you're talking to me because
I I can't say God is my father. But I
can shut up. I don't want to hear from
you anymore because you can't have a
conversation. You're disrespectful. Can
I talk to Jessica?
>> How is How is my husband disrespectful?
>> You want to keep shouting?
>> You want to No, you want to press what
you believe.
>> Can you open up what you believe? You
want to press it on me.
>> Hey, brother. You're I can't
>> even You're not even qualified to speak
in my place.
>> You're not even
>> open.
Not even your goddess is a fak open.
>> No. No. You're not even yourself. You're
not
>> throw out here if he doesn't stop
barking.
>> I will give you one word. Okay. Let me
see. Let me say I give you one word. No.
No. Has nothing to do with religion.
explain
to me.
>> Can you read?
>> I'll give you No, no. Now we
>> Okay, this guy's barking like a Can you
contact Jessica? Tell her husband to
muzzle it because he's acting like a
Are you a Your God is not even a fak.
You asking me to be a fak.
This is what happens when you marry
Muslim men, women. You get a like this
barking
who knows he can't defend his religion
and he manifests.
You saw I was very patient too, right?
Because he was scared he's going to lose
his wife. You're not getting it. He's
manifesting because his wife, he doesn't
want to lose her. He wants to keep her
as in the house so he can silly and make
her wear hijab. And then he can have a
second wife if he wants or a third and
fourth wife. So he's scared. Oh, I'm in
America so I can't in blue. She may
leave me. So I can't let her talk to
this guy.
That's what it is.
He's scared. That's what it is. So he
started barking. That's what you do,
ladies. Marry Muslim. Keep marrying
Muslim men.
So if she doesn't want to come back,
that's up to her. Her law say, "But this
is your religion." I couldn't even
get to the next verses because he
started manifesting. Are you a fake?
Your God is not even a
talking about me.
>> She can live in La La Land.
>> She
worships her husband, not God, because
her husband's controlled her. So there's
not much we can do for your sister.
So if not, then we'll move on, brother.
So you can just study the materials I
have online and you can then witness to
her because she's brainwashed. She's in
love with him. I think and if I ask you
these questions, don't get me wrong.
I want to ask you a question.
You said she's 36 years old, right?
>> This guy is blah blah blah.
>> Okay. So
>> I got to know
>> how long was she mar how long she
married to this guy?
for like over 10 years.
>> Oh, it's been 10 years now. She became
Muslim.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. No, like probably
>> 10 years they've been together and she
became like three years ago or four
>> 10 years she married a Muslim guy.
>> Wow. So
>> during that during
after after I think six years or five
years she she started telling all of us
she's Muslim. Oh, okay. So, she's been
married 10 years, I thought, recently.
Do they have kids?
>> Uh, no. They're about to.
>> Oh, poor lady. Her life is going to be
hell
>> then. Yep.